elle s'appelle line beurre weeds bolt
flash ou voy et sont devenus en moins
d'un an des éléments incontournables du
paysage parisien
impossible de faire quelques pas sur le
trottoir sont tombés sur une trottinette
électrique en libre service pratique bon
marché et amusant à conduire
elles ont séduit bien des parisiens
mais ces petits bolides sont loin de
faire l'unanimité
beaucoup d considère comme un danger
public comme une nuisance wyoming et de
ceux qui les détestent les gens qui s'en
servent ne savent pas s'en servir
simplement non nocere aucune règle
l'absence de régulation actuelle fait
que ces gars n importe où tu étais
n'importe comment à 2 vous voyez les
gens qui y vont à deux sous et
trottinettes électriques et on se croit
dans titanic mais c'est un peu la
version gilet jaune et d'italie on
compte aujourd'hui pas moins de douze
opérateurs de trottinettes électriques à
paris une flotte de plus de 20 mille
véhicules en libre-service qui
encombrent les trottoirs et roulent
souvent dessus le chaos auquel la ville
de paris a décidé de s'attaquer d'abord
nous avons sanctuariser les trottoirs
c'est à dire que nous avons dit pas de
trottinette sur les trottoirs ni pour
circuler ni pour se garer on garde les
trottinettes sur la chaussée après ça on
a demandé aux opérateurs de diminuer la
vitesse des trottinettes de 25 km heure
à 20 km/heure paris compte pour
l'instant sur le bon vouloir des eaux et
des eaux mais un projet de loi nationale
sur la mobilité devrait bientôt donner
aux villes les moyens de sévir contre
les usagers et de choisir les
fournisseurs de services pour être bien
vu de la mairie conscient qu'il n'y a
pas de place pour 12 les opérateurs
comme wind ont décidé de jouer le jeu on
a besoin d'être plus encadrées et 2
de mieux s'organiser pour éviter de
créer un désordre urbain que me certains
utilisateurs ont certaines personnes se
trouvaient si elle visait au départ à
limiter les excès des trottinettes en
émoi service les nouvelles
réglementations dans les faits
s'applique à tous les véhicules
individuels la propulsion électrique ce
qui créé bien des frustrations chez des
usagers qui crient à l'injustice
françois des landes par exemple utilise
sa propre trottinettes pour aller au
travail
dix kilomètres parcourus chaque jour en
silence sur des pistes cyclables et sans
polluer il porte un casque des gants et
n'encombre pas l'espace public puisqu'il
le gard jamais cette trottinette à
l'extérieur il vient de créer une
association pour tenter de faire en
temps à cause des trottinettes de
location on va se retrouver tous [ __ ] à
20 km/heure les gens ne voient ça que
par le prisme de la location oublie ses
350 mille personnes qui ont acheté du
matériel qui font leur mieux pour
respecter la législation actuelle selon
lui il est illogique de limiter à 20
km/heure les trottinettes personnel sur
les pistes cyclables
alors que les vélos à eux peuvent rouler
avec et évoluer si lentement dans les
rues au milieu des voitures
poseur risque pour la sécurité il ne
s'explique pas non plus l'interdiction
de rouler en dehors des villes
souhaitant faire entendre la raison où
on souhaite aussi montrer tous les
avantages qu'offre ce nouveau moyen de
transport
alors que la france safer combler le
vide juridique concernant ces nouveaux
moyens de transport les yeux du monde
entier sont rivés sur paris car des
solutions préconisées ici risque bien de
servir d'exemple pour le reste de la
planète
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada